[Music]
this is Alessandra and this is our
review and progress of Star Wars
Battlefront 2 if there's one thing that
Star Wars Battlefront 2 accomplishes
well it's the feeling of being in the
exciting universe of the legendary film
series serving up the greatest hits of
all things Star Wars the follow-up to
dices 2015 multiplayer focused game
presents a greater package of content
over its predecessor but overall it's
weighed down by an overbearing and
convoluted progression system that
doesn't seem to value the average
players time obscuring an otherwise
solid Star Wars experience said across
the backdrop of the entire Star Wars
saga Battlefront 2 expands the scope of
its galactic battles to great effect
from taking part in aerial dogfights
above Kamino to raiding the Death Star
to and escaping before its destruction
the sequel puts its 14 maps set across
the 40-year history of the series to
good use showing a clear difference in
aesthetics and tone from one time period
to the next
what's the plan come on keep getting
started for your snake the rebel can't
learn about on reason cinder
alike the first battlefront the sequel
contains a narrative driven
single-player campaign showing the fall
of the Empire and the eventual dawn of
the first order you take on the role of
iDEN versio commander of the Imperial
Special Forces outfit and Ferno squad
she normally works to undermine rebel
forces with covert missions and other
forms of espionage but after the fall of
the second Death Star her loyalties to
the Empire is tested when an
increasingly desperate Imperial Army
takes drastic measures to ensure its
future but they're not cool for you come
on diverse here is our target one of
them yes why the entire planet and its
people they're they're loyal to the
Empire the Emperor commands it will
purge this planet and others fear shall
spread and the galaxy will remember who
is in control commands while the brisk
four to five hour campaign features some
strong writing and performances from his
cast with some standout levels that show
off the visual lustre and diversity of
locations within the universe the
potential of its Imperial point-of-view
soon becomes lost falling into some
rather predictable twists the story
eventually turns into a familiar by the
number Star Wars adventure where the
good guys and bad guys are clearly
defined and with the lead up to the
final acts confrontation that signposted
from a mile away
if the Empire's here what I sensed was
true there must be something special
about this place
on occasion the campaign jumps to levels
that feature familiar faces adding some
moments of levity to the story those fun
and refreshing as they can be they come
off a bit too much like fanservice
leading Ida and versio to stand in the
shadow of others this is made worse by
an abrupt ending that teases future
updates to the campaign instead of
delivering a strong conclusion for its
hero's journey with that said the
campaign does a fairly decent job of
showing the internal strife within the
Empire's ranks even allowing you to
explore an imperial civilization on
ITINs homeworld of bardos but overall it
falls a bit short of making it a
remarkable journey for its characters
outside of the campaign and massive
multiplayer battles there are side modes
that offer some interesting diversions
the Arcade Mode makes a return featuring
themed levels where you battle AI BOTS
as classic light and dark side
characters
moreover the fan-favorite heroes vs.
villains mode is back letting players
cut loose with their favorite characters
cutting out unnecessary filler players
can choose their unlocked characters and
compete in four and four battles in over
the top and ridiculous fashion of your
time will be spent on the Galactic front
lines in battlefront two's multiplayer
while the 40 player conquest game type
galactic assault will likely be the most
popular game mode the upgraded
Starfighter assault deserves some
recognition
now with more responsive and tighter
controls for maneuvering your vessels
the aerial focus mode features
battlefront tuesd most intense missions
along with some stellar visual and sound
design the large-scale battles have the
same exciting flow as Star Wars as most
iconic fights where one heroic action
can turn the tide of a conflict another
victory for the first-order
your set of troopers starfighter classes
and hero characters can be boosted up
with star cards by amplifying stats
adding bonus attributes and even giving
characters alternate loadouts such as
replacing a heavy troopers energy shield
for a grenade launcher the number of
ways you can modify your characters is
impressive
[Music]
unfortunately this is where battlefront
two's multiplayer progression begins to
show its cracks getting a handle the
many systems gates and subtle nuances
therein can be confusing and off-putting
after each battle you'll collect
experience for your overall rank and
also credits to use for purchasing loot
crate's in the in-game store by relying
on randomly yielded weapons resources
and star cards of varying grades
battlefront - largely ties its
progression to dice rolls while you can
acquire an upgrade star cards on your
own by using crafting components found
from loot crate's this also leads into
the general problem of gating to upgrade
a card you have to ensure that your
class level and overall multiplayer
ranking meets certain standards while
also spending the fruits of your labor
on loot crate's for more resources and
cards simply focusing on the characters
and classes you like to play isn't
enough and the system in place all too
easily puts walls in front of you due to
the randomness and the inherent
dependence on the loot crate's
progression is often dictated by what
these results are this steers you away
from the classes you like and more
annoyingly results in cards for hero
characters you have yet to unlock while
the game gives you options to purchase
premium currency in the form of crystals
up to $100 worth these crystals can only
be used to buy more loot crate's this is
all made worse by the cumbersome menu
system which prompts you to exit out of
multiplayer games to collect your
rewards from milestones and challenges
while also obscuring vital information
such as player rank and class data the
biggest problem with the system is that
it's never clearly explained while
you'll come to understand how credits
crystals and crafting components are
used you'll have to reconcile that your
time invested in the game will always be
rewarded in the ways you expect in this
way battlefront to firmly plants itself
in the same territory as free-to-play
games with much of its content and
characters being tucked away behind
progression walls and the randomness of
the loot crate's
and this is an especially disappointing
impression to have from a full-price
release
above all it ends up doing a disservice
to the core gameplay itself which can
still provide those solid moments of
enjoyment despite the looming presence
of its progression systems many of these
issues related to the meta game fall by
the wayside when you're in the thick of
battle as you're taking part in the
massive struggle throughout the many
locales in the Star Wars universe while
its main narrative feels unresolved and
that general loop of the multiplayer
carries a number of issues Battlefront 2
still manages to evoke the same sense of
joy and excitement found in the core of
what the series is all about but as it
stands the biggest hurdle that
battlefront 2 will need to overcome for
its simultaneous attempts to balance
complex progression with the genuine
feeling of accomplishments is deciding
on what type of game it wants to be be
sure to check back next week for our
full review after we test the
multiplayer servers and other updates
[Music]
you